Biden's Energy Secretary getting the
cops called on her while trying to
promote his green agenda Jennifer
granholm roasting about a 4-day
multi-state road trip before things took
a really bad turn we're starting our
road summer road trip there we'll be
taking electric vehicles on this road
trip and um very excited to point out
all of the Investments that are
happening the Caravan of electric
vehicles quickly ran into problems with
broken Chargers and occupied stations
and after one staffer came up with the
idea to block the only working charging
Point port with a gas car for their
Entourage NPR reports quote a family
that was boxed out on a sweltering day
with a baby in the vehicle was so upset
they got boxed out that they decided to
get the authorities involved they called
the police now Dana M isn't the Energy
Secretary the woman woman who had some
ethical problems because she had all
this stock in ptera and electric
vehicles do you have to kind of question
her ethics and why is she so hot on this
well she's got away she's gotten away
with it right and the president is all
in and also because there's so many
subsidies you have the car company
saying okay we're we're going to we're
going to do it but what this whole
episode shows is that the electric
vehicle myth is that there is not the
appetite or the infrastructure to have
these mandates for electric vehicles yet
there was another story this weekend
about the rental car market and how what
it's just such a disaster for people
because they're really pushing the
electric vehicles on you and it's
causing huge problems because people
just want to get if you get a rental car
you want to get it and go you don't want
to have to relearn how to drive you
don't figure out how to charge it but
the for the fact that the advanced
people blocked the co blocked the family
so that she could get there to charge
her electric vehicle is something that
Selena Meyer never would have imagined
okay and so Jesse does doesn't that tell
you the staff is even worse than she is
it does I mean come on you have NPR
who's embedded yeah so you're trying to
impress NPR y so what if you have to
wait a little longer for some family to
charge up so what and it shows you she
doesn't want to be inconvenience because
judge even at the best charging station
it takes one to two hours to
recharge one to two hours versus 5
minutes it doesn't make any sense
Trump's got the great line I forget
where he said it it was like when
someone buys an electric car the first
15 minutes are fantastic and then the
rest of the time you're just nervous
about where you're going to charge and
also it's not making GM any money excuse
me Ford Ford loses
$60,000 per electric car per they only
sold 12,000 in the first quarter and all
of their factories went to Mexico it's a
boond doggle now Harold they just Biden
just banned Drilling in Alaska and anoir
why are they doubling down on this
disaster the same Advance Team that
secretary Grand has and the same
spokesperson that talked about Pearl
Harbor should both be uh they should be
let go and all seriously I think that um
I was an advanced guy for and I was I
was bad but I was not this bad there
were some things I didn't do for my my
then chairwoman of our party Alexis
Herman uh but grolm is smart she's
competent I wouldn't question her
Integrity anything like that but you
need a new Advanced team and you need to
go back to the drawing board let this be
a learning moment let's not try to try
this is just indefensible let's not try
to gloss over it go back and say what's
wrong why did this happen why do we not
have these charging stations or do these
things take too long challenge the car
companies uh to develop vehicles and
manufacture vehicles that don't take as
long ask them what they need on that
front those are the kinds of things I'd
be trying to do that I would try to
learn from this and share with the
nation and not try to defend the
indefensible Greg why are they so
embarrassed inly out of touch I think
you know what what's happening is people
don't want to admit that there's this
weird disorder going around called
charger anxiety and it's like the
electric car is replicating it in a
bigger way so like you have your phone
you have your like so I have an I have
an Apple Watch and and you know I have
to like always think about whether
that's charged I have to think about
whether my phone's charged whether my
laptop's charged now I have to think
about my car and it's like it's it's
like Jesse's right about and what Trump
said it's like it's fun until you're
anxious about it it it puts you back to
when you were 16 and you had your first
car and you only put two gallons of gas
in and you go maybe I can make it P to
the next exit you just be doing like
that but there's this is an old rule of
mine don't sail a boat while it's under
construction and that's what they did
they filmed it no doubt electric cars
will be part of these choices but you
need the in infrastructure first this is
why I've held off on my EV Bentley I'm
not I I I was thinking about it and then
I thought you know what I'm just going
to stick with the gas uh Bentley and my
Mini Coopers right what does Gus
prefer he loves a good Mini Cooper oh I
bet he does hi everyone I'm Brian killme
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now